okay so that was with a single variable
and usually when we do classification
we've got more than one variable
so now we're going to go to multivariate
gaussians
so here's a picture of a gaussian
density when we've got two variables
so it's one of these uh
fancy looking three-dimensional plots
it's beautiful beautiful isn't it
the Heights color-coded
could you make a plot like this right
I could try and then you'd criticize it
you do criticize it actually the the
beautiful thing is that R made this plot
with very little work from us right
um so there's two variables X1 and X2
and you can see the gaussian density in
two Dimensions looks like a bell
function
and this is left hand cases the case
when the two variables are uncorrelated
so it's just really like a bell
and the right hand case is when there's
correlation so now it's like a stretched
bill see this positive correlation
between X1 and X2
so those are pictures of the densities
the formula for the density doesn't look
nearly as pretty and here it is over
here
and it's somewhat complex we should go
over this in great detail now
excruciating detail please
I have a feeling that's a hint not to go
into it in great detail
anyway this is just a generalization of
the formula we had for a single variable
this is called The covariance Matrix and
it's if if you stay at this formula and
you stay at the previous formula you'll
see that there's there's somewhat
similarity especially if you know a bit
of vector algebra
um
if you go through the simplifications if
you know your linear algebra you can
form the and do the cancellation similar
to what we did before you can form the
discriminant function which is given
over here
um and it looks complex but important
thing to note is that it's again linear
in X yes X alone multiplied by a
coefficient vector
and this these are all just constants so
this again is a linear function
if the if the maths Beyond you don't let
it bother you this is a linear function
and we'll make that more clear a little
bit later on as well that this is a
linear function
um in fact we make it clear right here
it's might look complex but this can
just be written in this form over here
okay it's a linear function so the ck0
so this is a function for class K C K
zero
is built up of all these pieces over
here and then each of the coefficients
of X1 X2 up to XP come from this part
over here
remember X is a vector in this case
and so you can expand this expression
and get this this term over here
and I I probably I think I forgot to
mention it before what the idea of the
discriminant function is you compute one
of these for each of the classes and
then you classify to the class for which
it's largest
you pick the discriminant function
that's largest
well we can draw other nice pictures for
discriminant analysis similar to the one
dimension the the one-dimensional
picture we drew before
so here we've got two variables and
three classes
and we can't instead of showing those
density plots what we do is show
Contours in this case of the density so
here's the blue class and we shown that
the Contour of a particular level of
probability
okay for the blue class
for the green class and for the orange
class okay
and lo and behold and the decision
boundary is the dotted line yet
and it's really very pretty it it shows
you where you classify to blue versus
orange
and it's exactly where it cuts where the
con the line goes exactly through the
points where the Contours are cut
both for the orange to Blue for the the
blue to green and for the green to to
Orange and you can see they all meet in
the in the middle over here
right in the center over here
and so if you knew that the two
densities it would tell you exactly and
in this case the gaussian you get the
exact decision boundaries again these
are called the Bayes decision boundaries
these are the true decision boundaries
now of course we don't
but we go ahead and estimate the
parameters for the gaussians in each of
the class using formulas similar to what
we had before but appropriate for this
multivariate case so in this case we go
to get the mean
for X1 and X2 for the blue class
it's about there for the green class
with data points about there for the
orange class say there and and then we
plug them into the formula instead of
getting the the dotted lines we get the
solid lines and in this case it's
remarkably close
now these data were actually generated
from a gaussian distribution so it's not
too surprising that we got close but
with relatively few points we get
decision boundaries that look pretty
close to the the the real ones you
cannot learn about discriminant analysis
without seeing fish's Iris data it's
maybe one of the most famous data sets
around
it studies three species of of Iris
they these species are setosa versicolor
and virginica
and they color coded in this scatter
plot Matrix again with three colors in
this case
and they're four variables that are
going to be used to try and
automatically classify these these three
to these three classes
sepal length
sepal width petal length and petal width
so these are aspects of the of the
flower
and this 50 samples in each class
now if you look at these Scatter Plots
you can see that there's some really
good separation for example in this plot
of petal length and petal width the blue
class really stands out as being
different from from the other two
classes they seem to be more confused in
in some of the plots
but uh and and and in some of these
slightly more separation but the idea
here is to use all these variables
together to come up with a discriminant
rule and and classify
and so this was a motivated example that
uh that fisher used in in his first uh
description of linear discriminant
analysis and in fact it's often known as
fish's linear discriminant analysis
um importantly what comes as
discriminants analysis is a nice plot
right in this previous picture
there's four variables that we showed as
catapult Matrix of each variable against
the wrist but it turns out that there's
a single plot that captures
the classification information for all
of these variables
and here it is
and
I've got discriminant variable one and
discriminant variable two as the
horizontal and vertical axes
and it turns out these are linear
combinations of the original variables
but they especially the new combinations
and when you plot the variables against
these two you see really good separation
and these arise from actually performing
the linear discriminant analysis
because you've got three classes what
fish is linear discriminant analysis is
really doing or gaussian LDA is really
doing
is it's measuring which centroid is the
closest
but it's measured in a distance that
where it takes into account the
covariance of of the variables
um but ignoring the covariance for a
moment
the the distance the the three centroids
actually lie in a in a plane a Subspace
of the four-dimensional space
and it's really distance so if you have
three points they span a two-dimensional
Subspace
and that's essentially what we plot in
here is the two-dimensional Subspace so
see in which class is closest really
amounts to distance in that Subspace
and that leads to these nice low
dimensional plots
and so we have three classes here we can
make a two-dimensional plot and it
captures exactly what's what's important
in terms of the classification
and and when we have more than three
classes we can find still find two
dimensional plots but in that case it
doesn't capture all the information the
two-dimensional plot but you can find
the best two-dimensional plot for
visualizing the discriminant rule
and that's another important reason why
linear discriminant analysis is very
popular for multi-class classification
so keep in mind this case we had only
four features four variables right in
the scrim analysis was a very attractive
method but imagine we had four thousand
features ah right then an ingredient
what we just did was The covariance
Matrix we had to plug in an estimate of
the covariance Matrix yes and if we had
4 000 features that covariance Matrix
would be of size four thousand by four
thousand yes that's a that's a great
Point Rob and um you know we just can't
carry out discriminate analysis
um without other modifications if the
number of variables are very large and
we're going to talk about some ways of
doing that and later on in the class
we'll talk about even more ways
um
what we've talked about discriminator
functions which is telling you how you
classify but it turns out that you can
turn these into probabilities very
easily
and here's the expression over here
and so remember we got the decays by
doing a lot of simplification well it
turns out that those simplifications and
cancellations hold exactly for computing
the probabilities
so in other words those expressions we
had earlier for
Computing the probabilities let's go
back to it for example yes expression
here that's used in Computing the
probabilities
um where is it this this is the the
expression for the single variable case
with all these constants in that that
all the cancellation happens and we get
to
this nice simple expression over here
which just involves the discriminant
functions okay
so see you can see if you can actually
show that as well it's not that hard to
show and so
we can not only does discrimination
analysis give us a classify it also
gives us the probabilities
um when K is 2 will classify to class 2
if these probabilities are bigger than
0.5 else to class one just like in
logistic regression
use the credit data
um
and we produce in this case a
misclassification table
okay
so this table is has got
along the horizontal it's got the the
two status so it's a true default status
which is no or yes
you can see we had 10 000 samples in the
in the Credit Data
and not in the vertical we've got the
predicted status no or yes
so of course we'd like everything to lie
on the diagonal
it turns out we got a lot of the nose
right and and
not that many of the the yes is right
so on the diagonal is what you got
correct on the off diagonals is what you
got incorrect
nevertheless overall we make 2.75
misclassification errors here
okay so this is called a confusion
Matrix it tells how well you did
now there's some caveats this is
training error
right we've we fit the rule to these
data and now we see now will it performs
on these data so we may be overfitting
well we've got 10 000 training samples
here and we've only fit
um a handful of parameters so it's very
unlikely in this case that we're overfit
in for small training sets that would be
an issue and you need to have a separate
test set
um
another another uh thing to note is that
although 2.75 seems really good
misclassification right
if we just use a very naive
classification Rule and said I mean the
order always classified to the the
largest class in other words classify
according to the prior
we'd only make 3.3 uh three three
percent errors right because there's a
predominance of of nose in this in this
data set right the the total number of
nodes is 333 out of a out of ten
thousand right so this we call the null
rate
and so you always you always use a bear
in mind then the null rate when when
getting excited about a
misclassification error rate
the other thing to look at though is you
can break the errors into different
kinds so of the true nose
we make 0.2 percent errors so we hardly
ever misclassify a no
but of the yeses we make a whopping 75.7
errors right so the errors are very
lopsided in this case
and that's maybe not such a good idea
so
we
break down these errors into into finer
categories so we call the false positive
rate the fraction of of negative
examples that are classified as positive
right so they're false positives in that
case that was the 2.2 percent in this
case
and the false negative rate that's the
fraction of positive examples that are
classified as negative the 75.7 in this
case
now we produced the classification table
by
intuitively correct classifying default
is yes
um
if the probability of default was bigger
than 0.5
okay
but it gave us this very lopsided false
positive and false negative rate
um in some cases especially for these
kinds of screening examples
um you you may want to change the the
false positive and false negative rates
and skew them to one side or the other
right and you can do this by changing
this threshold instead of classifying in
this case to default if it's bigger than
0.5 you can change a threshold and maybe
make the threshold in this case smaller
so that you can catch more of the the
high risk cases for default
okay and so yeah we've done it as as a
function of the threshold and we've just
looked at negative thresholds or
decreasing thresholds
okay and so in this plot we've got in
Black the overall error rate
um in in in Orange we've got the false
positive rate and in blue we've got the
false negative rate
and so as we decrease the threshold the
false positive rate
increases because now we're going to
classify more and more negatives as
positive
but it increases very slowly you'll see
for a long region a long part of of the
threshold going down the decreasing
threshold the false negative false
positive rate doesn't increase very fast
of course the false negative rate
increases as we do that
and so even at Point at point one
right
um
the false the false positive rate hasn't
increased a huge amount and the false
negative hasn't increased a huge amount
but we've changed the balance of
classification
and so you can change the threshold
well you can capture that changing
threshold in what's known as an Roc
curve
so what this shows is
the two error rates in this case false
positive rate and true positive rate
um
as we change the threshold okay and
we'd like we'd like both we'd like the
false positive rate to be low and the
true positive rate to be high
and so this Roc curve traces out as we
change the threshold
and the 45 degree line is the kind of no
information line and what you'd like is
you'd like this curve to be right up as
far as possible into the top left hand
corner
so if you had a true positive rate of of
one and a false positive rate of of zero
you'd be on the straight line okay
and and so this is a single curve that
sort of captures the the behavior of the
classification rule for all possible
thresholds and you can and and you can
compare different classifiers by
comparing the ROC curves
okay
and to summarize it even more we
sometimes use the area under the curve
or AUC
which captures the extent to which you
up in the in the northwest corner then
higher AUC is good okay